is the summer movie season here not
quite yet but it's michael bay season
baby a two-hour long ambulance chase
sequence directed by michael bay picture
that in your head
the movie's generally exactly that
so ambulance is exactly what i said in
the intro of this video it's directed by
michael bay stars jake gyllenhaal and
yaya abdulmatine ii they play brothers
jake gyllenhaal is more the
he's the brash criminal of the two
brothers yaya abdulmatine the second
says ex-soldier but his wife is sick he
really needs money he hits up his
brother for a job the job is a little
more intense than he thought it was
gonna be and it becomes this whole thing
that he gets wrapped into and i mean now
they're going
70 miles an hour it's not stopping it
now and i gotta say this movie actually
took no time to get popping it was just
like okay we have a little bit of setup
great let's get to the action and when
it's in the pocket of these two criminal
brothers in an ambulance with a couple
of hostages in the back one's a wounded
cop who's unconscious for
99 of the movie yeah there's an emt in
the back of the ambulance played by aza
gonzalez who's trying to keep this
wounded cop alive while cops are chasing
the ambulance is all going 70 miles an
hour all the way
all michael to the bay when it's in the
pocket there matt it's actually absurdly
entertaining granted sometimes this
movie does slide into some of those
michael bay isms that does give you
those eye rolls but i was really loving
the high octane nonsense you know it was
just like why crash one cop car when you
can crash what you know seven three of
them will explode with those firework
explosions kind of reminded me of
cyberpunk 2077 you'll just be doing your
thing and this car will just be like
right past your like whoa
the bugs in this game turns out hey
maybe the game wasn't buggy at all just
showing you what cyberpunk 2077 would be
if michael bay directed it i kind of
blew past the cast let's go back to the
cast for a second jake gyllenhaal i
thought was great for this movie there's
a cartoonish element to his character
but it's in this movie every character
slides into a caricature cartoon version
of their character at least at one point
it might just be for one scene and then
it's done but everyone in this movie has
it happened to them jake gyllenhaal's
the one where generally it worked for
him his eccentricity i thought was just
it fit maybe i just appreciated the fact
that gyllenhaal was having so much fun
in this film you know just like okay
we've seen jake gyllenhaal but have we
seen michael bay jake gyllenhaal i had a
good time with it at a point though they
do something with his character where i
was like you
you changed his character and he's much
less interesting now yaya abdul martin
ii brings great contrast to that
relationship between the two between
that brotherhood whereas jillian holds
the eccentric [ __ ] yaya abdul martin
the second is
he's a good dude he's just
here now because he chose to be yes
but he's here now asa gonzalez i thought
was a standout in this movie i thought
she was the heart of the entire story
because i guess i was really surprised
when i first saw her i was like yeah the
hot chick in the michael bay movie i get
it's kind of his formula but she brought
so much more to the role and to the
movie i was just i was really surprised
how by the end of this whole thing she
was such an anchor to the story and as
entertained as you might be all right
let's talk about hey yeah those michael
bay isms you've seen before and they're
back now first of all that the movie
being about a half an hour too long yup
this movie would be a perfect 90 minute
film no it has to go over two hours why
because michael bay then again that
might just be trailers god how long are
trailers now holy [ __ ] hard to gauge the
run time of a movie these days you're
like oh two and a half hours no 45
minutes of that was trailer but the
movie does undeniably run too long
there's this goldilocks zone you feel
that zone pass and now you're you're in
overtime and as i've seen michael bay do
before it's not just him i've seen other
movies do this too that thing where you
have a locked in premise and a small
cast that completely works somewhere
going into the third act you have this
whole other crew that just shows up and
now they're doing stuff and they got to
deal with that now granted there were a
couple of phone calls leading up to it
not going to say there's not but when
it's actually executed just feels so
weirdly out of place kind of feels like
cinematic dlc you know where the video
game would be oh it's the ambulance you
gotta run from the cops and that's the
game and the dlc is oh now there's this
new tension this new situation with this
whole other crew outside that premise
and now they got to deal with that but
hey dlc but it's like the dlc dropped
when you were part way through the
actual vanilla storyline and you're like
i
so now there's this it's
well i feel like i was supposed to beat
the game then play the dlc as it says
dlc just plopped in the middle of my
game and it just feels weird yeah this
game runs into that too not game movie
sorry now i'm in game mode look what
this did to me i gotta give props though
to the the flow and ebb of thoughts and
emotions i had just like with one scene
in particular this thing is going down
in the ambulance it's the medical
procedure completely impossible at 60
miles an hour you're just like this is
this
this is
ridiculous it's just a word then there's
this however in all fairness that scene
is the most tension-filled scene in the
entire movie but all of it hit me at
once it was this mental rollercoaster i
was on literally in real time like
that's ridiculous dude you're gonna lose
and be careful right it would make zero
sense if i wasn't talking about a
michael bay film guys in the end if
you're a michael bay fan you're gonna
dig this one no doubt if you're not a
michael bay fan you might very well find
this pleasantly surprising pleasantly
entertaining in that popcorn way this is
the most fun i've had in a michael bay
filming years it's not perfect has to
trademark michael bay flaws except you
know ruining transformers lore that's
not in here i'm just gonna say i had
myself a good time with this one no
alcohol required or some ambulance have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite michael bay movie
they actually referenced a couple of
them in this movie they referenced the
rock and bad boys i don't know it's a
weird call michael bay's like we're
going to reference my own movies in my
movie
good for him whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you